hi today I want to talk about some of my
ideas surrounding why people get
interested in studying physics or
wanting to be a physicist in the first
place now this is just going to be my
opinions so you can let me know how
relatable this is but essentially I
think that if you look around you know a
physics class people that are majoring
in physics you will find maybe more so
than many other you know subjects that
the people in this class are really
inspired driven and passionate about
studying physics and wanting to be a
physicist there will be some people
there who I guess have just taken the
class because they needed to fill a spot
but I think for the most part physics
really attracts people who I guess feel
destined to study physics and I think I
wonder a little bit about why this is
and I think about my own journey to
wanting to pursue physics and to be a
physicist and I think one of the things
that contribute to it is that people
really do like the challenge and the
challenge comes from physics reputation
as being quite difficult when I learnt
about physics for the first time it was
reading books about you know famous
physicists whether it's like Albert
Einstein or Richard Fineman something
like that and some of the contributions
they've made over the history of science
and maybe it takes a little bit of
arrogance on my part or maybe it's just
a bit of confidence to read about these
discoveries and think I would like to
have my name added to this list like I
would like to make some contribution
that's in line with the contribution
that these people have made because I
just admired them so much I think it's
natural for anyone to want to make some
kind of contribution to the world and
for people to want to be remembered and
I think wanting to be remembered or have
you named down amongst the greats
and like a book about the history of
science is one of the best ways I could
imagine
being remembered like I said maybe it
does take a certain level of confidence
to want to read about this stuff and
think that you're good enough or smart
enough to even you know comprehend or
contribute to these things but maybe
that confidence is what you need and is
probably a good thing to motivate you
through all the difficult studying I
also think it's why physics attracts
people that do you know quite well
academically I think it's a bit of a
positive feedback loop like if you're at
school say and you're doing well in your
classes on math and science you kind of
you know your ego gets a little inflated
and you think you're you're just good at
this stuff so what should someone do if
they are good at this stuff well they
should pursue maybe being the best at
this stuff and maybe that naturally
leads people who do well it in some of
these classes to want to pursue being a
physicist because I think it's seen as
you know one of you know the pinnacles
of the field I think it's also natural
for people to like challenging
themselves a bit maybe if even if you
don't truly believe you're ever gonna
win a Nobel Prize I think you know it'd
be hard to find any aspiring physics
student who wouldn't like that idea you
know like the idea of doing something
really great within physics
and like I think it's just human
psychology if you just are you know in a
social gathering and you have some
riddle maybe that you pose for people to
want to try and attempt or solve I think
you have people just wanting to work on
it and you'll find some people who get
really obsessed with it and wanting to
solve the problem that you're posing to
them whether it's to prove that they are
smart or just to flex you know their
mental abilities I think it's just a
natural thing for people to enjoy
challenges and like academic challenges
and puzzles are very much a part of
physics and being a physicist I spoke
about reading books about like the
history of science
and I guess this is just my experience
but when I read those books and whenever
I do read a book about awesome stuff
going on in science or even just
articles about it
my natural feeling is to think I would
like to be a part of this like when I
read about mysteries and unsolved
problems and for the physics I feel like
I want to be a part of solving it I
guess I would find it hard to just read
the information and be happy with having
no part in wanting to pursue the answer
but I guess a lot of people do feel that
way because there's many more people
reading about science discoveries and
interested in them then there are people
actually actively pursuing physics and
maybe that just comes down to I guess
maybe their own opportunities maybe
everyone who does read these articles
would like to be a physicist but I guess
that's not possible if you've already
got a career in something else you're
already in some other direction I guess
there is a sweet spot of you know being
inspired and being able to pursue it
that maybe I was lucky to just be swept
along with but yeah definitely whenever
I read about physics I feel this urge to
be a part of it and saying that I don't
really know like if I ever will make a
contribution because right now I'm
pursuing things like science
communication more than I am pursuing
trying to make some discovery but we'll
see what happens in a few years I guess
I don't really know what my future holds
this is just I know my feelings that
have gotten me this far another aspect
that I think contributes to people
feeling destined to study physics is
that physics relates to trying to
understand the nature of reality like I
don't want to sound too like off in the
clouds when I'm talking like that but
that inherently to me still is what
physics is about it's trying to gain
some answers from this vast sea of just
unknown because I think for maybe some
people who study physics it is their
religion and it because
that I think people are attracted to you
know typical religion because it takes
this very confusing world where we have
no answers and nothing really makes
sense and it gives some like glint of
meaning or you know a comfort and
understanding what this is all about and
what will be here after we're gone and
whilst you can definitely be religious
and a physicist for some people physics
becomes the only religion that they have
the only you know glint of meaning
amongst all this you know stuff going on
in the world I think almost when you
think about physics and you think about
pursuing some of these really big
questions and you know this really you
know fundamental truth of what the world
is everything else and every other topic
can seem mundane and to terrestrial in a
way I have definitely felt in the past
like you know physics is the only thing
worth studying and everything else is
just a waste of time like even you're
just doing random chores I'm like this
is such a waste of time when we could be
you know really looking for answers but
maybe I've calmed down a little bit
about those thoughts I think you know
definitely you can be happy studying
something other than physics or just
doing something else entirely but maybe
for me my fulfillment does come from
never losing track of thinking about
some of these things thinking about you
know what the world is made of and
thinking about things from the I guess
point of view as a physicist but yeah
that aspect of physics I think really
does contribute to people feeling like
they're distant to study it because they
can't imagine themselves doing anything
else there nothing else provides them
with that same fulfillment and all of
these things that I've said are a great
advocate for physics but they can also
lead to great disappointment I mean if
you're going into this thinking that
you're going to be the next Einstein
that you're going to win a Nobel Prize
which actually I know many students you
know they have this wish in their mind
and they want to work towards it it
means you've got really high
expectations and it means that whatever
the reality is that you achieve maybe
it's not going to live up to those
expectations and that lends itself to
you know room for a lot of
disappointment and maybe unhappiness
from never fulfilling expectations I
guess this is a bit of a different
thread but my personal philosophy is
that happiness and expectations are very
related to each other and so the higher
you have your expectations whilst it can
motivate you to do things you might not
otherwise be doing it's probably not the
best road to happiness that's just my
thoughts around that so I guess it's a
little bit dangerous to to think you're
going to get a Nobel Prize and you're
going to have your name recorded in
history alongside some of your heroes
and the people that have inspired you
but I don't think that shouldn't really
discourage anyone from at least giving
it a go let me know what you think if
you're on this road as well of wanting
to be a physicist are you setting your
expectations pretty high for yourself or
you know how did you even get this idea
of pursuing it in the first place I'd
like to take a chance to thank brilliant
org for sponsoring my channel if you're
wanting to pursue physics or even max
and other aspects of science brilliant
is a great place to go it's a resource
where you could take quizzes courses
they have also a lot of animations and
great explanations of some of these
science concepts that I think are
helpful for people wanting to learn this
content especially if you're just
learning on your own
brilliant also have a mobile app and you
can download courses to take them
offline so
if you're traveling or on the go you can
still keep up with learning and it's
probably more productive than doing
something like scrolling through
Instagram so thank you - brilliant and
if you would like to sign up for free
you can go to brilliant org slash
Tibby's and the first 200 people to
follow that link can get 20% off an
annual premium subscription thank you
for watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]